there is a problem with Twitter Facebook
all these things being cheap and being
free it shouldn't be free because if it
is free you can use bots to create
imaginary issues what were you going
with no I would the problem is it isn't
free they are divisive there are many
other things because they're not free
people think that they're free they
don't see the cost but whenever you have
this free ment sort of mantra it is in
reality anything but free we have a
system that sells you you put in your
information you put in your photos and
they own it all they get to use it all
they get copyright over what you're
doing they get access to all you're
saying they get to sell your information
basically do either governments or
businesses or whatever else so people
can find out where you go what you do
and then they can do that to promote
advertising and sales and whatever else
and things you don't need or want and
ideas that really shouldn't be there
yeah
why because Twitter makes a few cents
every time so rather than having
knowledge of what things actually cost
we have a hidden cost now the SEC back
in 1999 actually took action against a
number of decentralized companies who
were saying that they were giving out
shares and saying that they're not
covered because well that new technology
they can do web IPOs which is the modern
word so is called an ICO and they were
issuing shares if people signed up on
their site so you put in your your name
address and some personal information
and they gave you shares and guess what
every time you put a mere email address
back in 1999 when there weren't that
many email addresses when advertising
wasn't that big the SEC analyzed that
and
came up back then with your information
was worth eleven dollars just by doing
that little bit so right now we are in a
world where we have much more
information where the richness of
information about your life if you have
facebook on your phone is incredibly
deep and now we're selling all that
information and it's not eleven dollars
anymore it's not cheap
now Facebook couldn't make money without
doing all this imagine if every day they
got half a cent from you they'd still be
profitable imagine half a cent from all
their people they'd be very profitable
that people can even have blog posts and
whatever else that they sell other
things that they do online and they can
make money without having to have bank
accounts set up all sorts of things yet
that's not what we're doing because L
billions of dollars of advertising most
of which is not really what anyone ever
wants if Facebook got a half a cent
every day from every user at 2.2 billion
that's some 330 million a month times 12
is not a lot of money it's four billion
a year they wouldn't be as profitable as
they are today not the negative the
negative how much did I get right now
not in revenue but in profit it's a lot
more than four billion it's a lot more
than four billion I mean I know he lost
money seven billion last week but the
only reason I'm asking this is because
I'm business model now you made me know
it's a smarter which is a complete
different topic can a business model of
charging me every day a certain amount
really work for others to get and will
it can it scale to 2.2 billion I don't
know can scale to 2.2 billion users
you
[Music]